but he finally has no excuses chris it
took about eight months for him to have
no excuses one of the most
significant moments of the early regular
season in 2020 the thursday night game
against the bears
the i thought it would it's still it's
not fourth down here's
here's brady revealing that he truly was
clueless in that moment
you guys remember this one fourth
quarter
last chance in chicago i thought it was
the second to last chance
in chicago but apparently not i don't
think i've ever been as confused as i am
in this moment right here
[Applause]
[Music]
i i love it when a guy can be
self-effacing
self-deprecating i i really like that
but you know what
uh he wasn't that way at the time there
he is exiting the field without shaking
nick foles hands
shades of super bowl 52 uh
look he's a human he's embarrassed he's
got an ego shocking tom brady has an ego
but uh again i don't know he gets credit
for coming clean eight months later
let's hear what
both tom brady and bruce arians had to
say chris about this
at the time that it happened yeah i
don't care about it eight months later
let's hear from brady and from arians
from the time that it happened
the final play uh you were i mean they
made mention that maybe you didn't know
it was broke down i
can't imagine that was the case what was
you know it was fourteen five you took a
shot they were great
yeah i knew we needed a chunk and i was
thinking about more yardage
and then uh you know it was just it was
bad execution
and we had a great opportunity there so
just didn't uh
didn't execute when we needed to it
looked like tom might have been confused
with what down it was did he not know it
was fourth down
yeah he knew he knew
yeah he knew look i wha what's what's
what's wrong
it's okay we make mistakes it's okay
nothing wrong with admitting
that a mistake was made and again it
takes some of the
it just it's it's it's great it's great
to see him do it now
but it takes something out of it when
you consider that
thou shalt not mention that the great
tom brady may not have known what down
it was
in the immediate aftermath of the game
happening chris no i know i mean yeah i
would have
liked to have seen them be honest in the
moment and just yeah i messed up
whatever i
you know and yeah i am a little shocked
too like right like you see on social
media everyone's like well look
that's why i like him he came clean like
no that doesn't count as coming clean
after you know the storybook was written
and it happened to have a happy ending
now it's easy to dive back and make fun
of yourself that's where i would
want a question too if they don't win
the super bowl win the super bowl
there's no way he does that there's no
way you never seen that
you can have fun with it now because you
won the super bowl because you say hey
everybody kiss my butt
i got a big seventh drink and a super
bowl trophy
yeah so eat that but i don't think he
ever says that if that doesn't happen
and let me tell you if they had ended up
missing the playoffs by
one game it never would have been
mentioned
ever again whenever he writes his
memoirs
it never would have come up forget about
that
we shall not discuss the moment that
ultimately was the dagger
for our hopes in 2020 so uh yeah it it
is easy to joke about it after you've
won the super bowl and as you're getting
closer and closer to the night where
there will be gathering somewhere
to get ring number seven what will he
show up to get ring seven
with the other six i think so so he can
yeah he can do a little of that yeah all
of them on there
why not i mean you you've done they're
not buccaneers rings
i know so what you've done it every
other year you got a t-shirt that says
your name and seven on it
so what show all seven damn you're the
only one that's got seven of them
so do it will he put the new ring on a
middle finger
probably i don't know yeah i don't know
he might he might do that yeah just like
send it up to like the the patriots
organization like hey look what i found
this year
uh i don't know but brady brady
like you know love his leadership
loved the way he is in so many ways but
yeah we've seen
ego get the best of them or maybe being
a sore loser a little bit everybody's
not a good loser no doubt
and and maybe maybe that's one of the
reasons why he's won as much as he has
and again this is something that we've
discussed and and it really is a
fascinating disconnect to me
behavior and attitudes that we find
objectionable in children
and try to try to parent out of them
why do you have to you don't have to win
all the time can you please stop stop
stop cheating no
you don't own park place your sister
does okay
you don't have to win every game of
monopoly you don't have to win every
game of part cheesy it doesn't have to
be that way
we admire that yeah behavior
in athletes i know you're exactly right
but it's the way we want them we want
our athletes to kind of be
cut throat competitive you know we like
to see that aspect and especially when
it becomes like
that great player like a brady because
then we start to dive deeper into like
oh the psychology of what
made him and all of those type of things
that's where i think it kind of gets a
life of its own a little bit there but
hey say what you want like bruce erie
and says the greatest leader in the
history of the sport
obviously one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time um but yeah i
would have liked to have seen him be a
little bit more
you know truthful there when the time
was
one thing that nick foles will always
have and can't be taken away no matter
how far he is on the bears depth chart
or anyone else's
twice in his career he humbled brady to
the point
where brady slinked off to the locker
room
without shaking nick foles hands not
once yeah but
twice yeah that's impressive it is
impressive there's no doubt i mean foles
is
he's never been affected by the
situation that's for sure i don't i
never looked at bad play or things like
that to go foles is feeling the pressure
it's just not good
i just think you know he's just a good
quarterback not a great quarterback and
those type of things but
yup he's one of the few right that can
kind of like
have that pelt on his horse like when i
play tom brady
he loses and i win that's a pretty cool
thing to say to your gran your grandkids
i wonder if bruce arians has ever
responded in practice
to a bad throw by tom brady by making a
comment like what do i have to do go
trade for nick foles
[Laughter]
that's probably a line that even bruce i
bet you bruce
i don't think he would cross that one
either i bet you bruce bruce has plenty
of things he could say
if it's an underwhelming throw or he
doesn't like it that are very witty
uh there's no doubt bruce i i don't even
know him but just being around him the
few times we have real quick at like the
combine and things like that
man he's awesome he's awesome he's as
quick as a quick as there is i mean
you know i i i think i've told the story
before i asked him one time i said you
still got pictures over that facility of
me
and you know as he's walking off said he
goes yeah somewhere by the training room
and kept walking
amazing come back way to go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports